this is a remarkable thing to watch
unfold normally we see black and white
videos on the history channel of what
war looks like and here it is right in
front of us joey let's go to you you've
been in the arena you've been in the in
a war theater you know of course what
can happen in that dynamic uh the
mirapul theater is a in a lot of news
it's a historic theater but this is
about civilians and destroying civilian
cities sometimes military targets but
not always what are your thoughts on how
this is proceeding yeah the idea of
targeting civilians is incomprehensible
for me i mean we saw the taliban do
similar things um and it really was the
one thing that kept us wanting to fight
if you deployed in 2010 you might not
have known what the fight in afghanistan
was but you know that taliban were bad
guys and the chance to go kill someone a
bad day
what we see here
i mean we can put things into context
they're still fighting for mariopol not
odessa and that kind of tells you where
they are for the plan they had for where
they are and we can say they're outside
of kiev they're not in kiev and we're
four weeks into it but we can also say
they probably can can fight this as long
as they need to and so the concern is we
sit here two months from now
russia has ukraine the only thing that
changed from russia's plan to where we
end up might just be that a lot more
ukrainians are dead and a lot more
ukrainian buildings have fallen that's
not what we want and that's what we're
hoping doesn't happen
uh alicia right now we're hearing also
of this allegedly a hypersonic missile
being used we don't have confirmation of
that but that could be propaganda we do
know of course already a hospital has
been hit we know children and and
women women in labor not having died
from that
this is certainly not uh reflecting well
on russia they must know what's
happening to their reputation regardless
of what happens at the end of the war uh
when even with their own economy how do
you see this playing out and is any of
that affecting what putin is deciding to
do
well only putin knows that and maybe a
couple of people around him from
everything we understand from our
reporting um he is really the one who's
holding all the cards here and those
around him do live in fear um hearing
greg talk about uh the intelligence here
that we're talking about the probability
of months
and as joey said you know we're talking
about additional horrors that we're
going to see
how much the world will be able to
stomach it remains to be seen we simply
don't know um but since the beginning um
the question has been what is putin
thinking we know he doesn't care just
from his actions what the world believes
of what he is doing because as we have
seen he has continued to lie against all
evidence um to his own people of what
exactly is happening in ukraine and his
mission there so tammy it's it's really
hard to say it just sounds like we are
getting ourselves ready for something
even worse
yeah i think we've got some time in the
uh later in the show we're going to be
talking more about putin and in this
case charlie you know you've got you've
got zelinski who is like a now an
international hero
for standing up for his country but he's
making demands
that americans understand are are almost
go to too far like the the no-fly zone
that effectively is engaging in this war
do you think that push is going to
continue there there is a bipartisan
group from congress going uh to to meet
uh with him and at least some other
leaders i believe uh what do you think
we're going to end up doing here to help
well i think that uh so far uh you know
obviously there's a lot to criticize
about the america's handling of this
this administration's handling of this
from the very beginning but i do think
that probably the tempered political
approach uh being very very careful
about walking a fine line between
helping rebuff an inve the invasion by
russia by putin
and uh and not prolonging a war that is
terrible for ukrainians
and i think you know we've heard some
talk about about efforts uh to try to
broker peace deals uh that would stop
the killing um i think all of that is uh
probably very very uh you know it's you
never know dealing with a guy like uh
vladimir putin if there is any sort of
um weird uh
uh
silver lining out of any of this it's
that i think that the world has seen uh
vladimir putin's true colors what he is
capable of and when you see these the
you know there's a lot of um uh you know
propaganda going around all over the
place but we do see civilians in ukraine
being targeted and that's uh that
reveals vladimir putin's true colors and
uh he will never live that down the the
world will never forget that you're not
kidding all right everyone's had one one
quick point um
sorry to interrupt but um you know this
week the secretary of defense lloyd
austin did say that a no-fly zone would
likely not have the impact that we would
imagine
that it would have first of all there
are missiles we know from intelligence
reports and from what the secretary of
defense said himself that are coming
from inside russia and that with this
also gives us an added risk of u.s
troops and nato troops getting ever
closer to the battlefield great point
yeah this is a matter of whether or not
what's being shot is is coming from the
air versus being artillery that a no-fly
zone is not going to be stopping
excellent points hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else